and here's the other thing about our
sofa tonight - pop stars James Corden
and yet they all have had a number one
single - yeah very how many of you have
you've had ten ten here oh yeah yes a
bunch anyway you've had a law a handful
yeah James the one was one there's a
terrible song for charity
yeah one even now Paul McCartney a lot
of guests have a guest
Casey and James how many not want is it
which which albums are we counting here
am i single table talking single solo
right they dumped yeah if he's not I'm
Singh this is single number one six I
think 55
I think 42 okay disappointing now it's
it's gonna be yeah priced right and
lower try and lower
I've only been going for like five years
I've had one I'm not even a saying
he's nothing ethical grave that's what
we're trying to get across my guy is it
more than 10 yes yes I think at 21 oh
that's good guess 20 I twenty four yes
this is the kicker though so twenty four
singles but he has spent ninety eight
weeks at number one
Wow ninety-eight years
is watching from Aberdeen I just need to
sell one more ticket and there will be
more people in the audience than there
are on stage and that's what we need
please I love Aberdeen as well can I
just take this opportunity I'm a big fan
yeah you don't you'll be in in your
husband will be sob yeah you went 12 I
what husband we've all been around the
block Jonah this break Edwards yes well
what a legend